hey rockstar do you know if your r and
python packages are out for delivery let
me show you how to know
head over to our studio package manager
you'll probably land on the top repo
your system administrator has set up for
you in the top navigation bar head over
to setup
scroll down below the calendar click on
the change link
select the operating system that your
ide is running on in my case that's
ubuntu 20.04 select ok
select the binary button this ensures
you'll be installing pre-compiled binary
versions of the packages saving you
hours of time
click the copy button to copy this
unique url to your clipboard
then head back over to
your rstudio ide
in the tools menu at the top
go down to global options
in the left sidebar
click on packages
and then the change button
and then paste in the url that you
copied from package manager click ok and
okay that's it
that's the simplest way to connect
rstudio package manager to your rstudio
ide it can be a lot more complicated
than that there's multiple ways to do
this but this is your first step give it
a shot bring those packages home
[Music]